thank you
uh
the committees will come to all
i am pleased to open today's joint
hearing
of the committee on armed services
and the committee on foreign relations
on u.s policy regarding iraq weapons
inspections
let me first welcome my fellow chairman
senator lugam
who is filling in for chairman helms
who unfortunately could not attend today
and all of our colleagues from the
committee on foreign relations to their
sharing
i expect we'll be able to gain valuable
lights insights on this important
national security and foreign relations
policy
i also want to welcome our witness major
scott ritter
former chief of the consumer and
investigation unit
united nations special commission on
iraq
the basis for all our problems on this
matter
has not changed
iraq dictator saddam hussein
wants to retain
chemical and biological weapons
so he can use them
to menace or attack his neighbors
and even iraqi citizens who oppose him
saddam a pathological killer
won't see his weapon so badly that he
has been willing to let the iraqi people
anguish on the economic sanctions for
seven years
the armed services committee is very
concerned
about our military objectives in the
persian gulf
and the status of our military forces
who have been deployed in this region
for an un for an extended period of time
the effect of such diplomacy on
readiness and morale is significant
saddam hussein has crafted
played provocative ranksmanship for
several years
causing the u.s
to constantly react
incurring large expenditures for foster
plumbers to the gulf
even with a recent withdrawal drawdown
of deplored forces the united states
still maintains almost 20 000 military
personnel
in the persian gulf area
my concern over the use of the u.s
forces
is directly linked to our foreign parts
in this area
it has been my understanding the u.s
process supported the inspections by
unscom
and that we were prepared to back that
policy for with folks if necessary
i believe that safety policy is critical
to our leadership role
on the security council of the united
nations
and essential to the effectiveness of
one's com
curbing haddam sustains blatant behavior
is now linked to a u.n agreement and
resolution which threatens
various severe consequences
if iraq obstructs inspection of
suspected military installations
recent news reports indicating that u.s
resolve may have weakened
has caused concern in the congress
on april 6 the president submitted a
report to congress which clearly stated
that a diplomatic solution
has been tried
the administration's alternative
was a memorandum of understanding
however iraq has not been held
accountable on this agreement
that they have signed with the secretary
general
and which was endorsed by the security
council in this resolution 1154.
the u.s had warned iraq that compliance
on this agreement
invoke this various consequences
however recent press reports indicate
that u.s officials
may have discouraged unscrum from
conducting necessary inspections
where the intelligence indicating the
need for such inspections is difficult
to obtain
and highly perishable
the u.s has just taken direct action
against afghanistan and
and the sudan
where we recognized a threat to our
nation and the international community
this is commendable
however iraq continues to refuse to
cooperate with the u.n mandate
which requires that it reveal and
destroy weapons of mass destruction
similar to those
osama bin laden was producing in sudan
why has the united states decided to
to act against bin laden and not against
iraq
which represents a direct threat to our
national interest and the gulf region
at a time when united nations weapons
inspectors
said they are closing in on hiding
places
west dam has established his deadly
viruses and nerve gases
the u.n security council
and the u.s government have not enforced
the inspections right to inspect
if saddam will not let the united
nations weapons inspectors resume their
inspections then the u.s must exert its
leadership in the security council and
along with our allies
take military action to exac severe
consequences for saddam's refusal
experience of the past seven years shows
that the threat or use of force against
iraq
has in effect been effective in
achieving a variety of objectives
it is incorrect to state that the use of
the military option has been ineffective
ought to imply that his past approach
failed because it placed insufficient
emphasis on diplomacy
force and diplomacy are two sides of the
same coin
the so-called diplomatic option alone
is not a viable long-term approach
its adoption by the administration
marginalizes unscom
weakens the policy of containing iraq
and advise further challenges by an
emboldened saddam
setting the stage for further
confrontation with iraq
the united states is again in the odd
position of bargaining with a tyrant and
war criminal who is dodging long overdue
compliance with lies and empty promises
i am pleased that major riddle has
consented to appear before our
committees to give us his views on this
important matter major wilder
served with the u.s marine corps as an
intelligence officer in the gulf wall
he has been on the
unscum inspection team since 1991.
he is known to have been a tough
demanding inspector
he has indicated that he has chosen to
resign from one's calm
because he felt that the united states
and the u.n security council
were not providing adequate support to
unscom
saddam hussein
had reason to fail major brothers
expertise and perseverance
and continually tried to have him
removed from the unscum and iraq
i regret that he is no longer an
uncommon spectrum
i felt better knowing that he was on the
job
i know all of us are looking forward to
hearing from this dedicated american
as a combined membership of our
committees towards up to 36 members
it would be a challenge to conduct these
sharings in a manner
that ensures that each and every member
has afforded the opportunity to be
recognized
therefore i will diligently enforce the
five-minute rule
i urge the cooperation of all members in
closely adhering to this limit
in order to accommodate as many members
of questions as possible
i will recognize the acting chairman of
the foreign relations committee
as well as the ranking members of each
committee for five minutes
opening statements which are also much
strictly enforced then following a major
other statement each sentence will be
allowed five minutes for questions
let me now recognize
senator luga the acting chairman of the
committee on foreign relations for any
opening remarks he might like to make
senator thank you very much
mr chairman this hearing affords both of
our committees an excellent opportunity
to review international efforts and
specifically our united states role and
policy to stop iraqi programs involving
weapons of mass destruction
for more than seven years we've been
engaged in an international effort to
prohibit iraq from producing biological
chemical and nuclear weapons
and the missile capability to deliver
them
it has been an unprecedented
collaborative effort to stem
proliferation of weapons of mass
destruction
success or failure will set a precedent
the outcome is critically important to
the security interest of all countries
during these seven years saddam hussein
has dodged weaved and deceived the world
community in order to limit and to avoid
international monitoring and inspections
of iraq's weapons facilities
he has repeatedly grabbed the initiative
and forced international inspectors in
newscom to respond last fall saddam
hussein dramatically broke off
cooperation with international
inspectors expelled u.s unscom
inspectors and provoked a protracted
confrontation which resulted in the
threatened use of military force to
compel iraqi compliance with the un
resolutions
that crisis was resolved in february to
the intervention of un secretary general
kofi and anne
this threat of force at that time gave
credibility to international diplomatic
efforts and made the anand agreement
possible
the administration accepted the inan
agreement but threatened quote the
severest consequences in a quote if iraq
failed to comply with the agreement
that threat of force is essential and
must remain
the use of force must be a credibly
viable option
the inaud agreement came unglued last
month when iraq again ceased cooperating
with unscom
uscom has not been able to carry out
this mission since early august
we are again at a serious crisis point
with iraq
no one appears to be quarterbacking a
game plan in which intrusive inspections
continue and produce results we have
noted for some time that international
apathy has been creeping into
enforcement of the inspection regime in
iraq there appears to be a steady
erosion of international will within the
u.n security council the united nations
and among regional states who should
have the most to fear from a resurgent
iraq armed with weapons of mass
destruction
these divisions in the coalition against
iraq may have encouraged saddam to defy
u.n resolutions and interfere again with
u.n monitoring and inspection missions
the united states has been the most
insistent country on the right to
inspect iraqi facilities anytime and
anywhere and to destroy those materials
and weapons proscribed in u.n
resolutions
we have over the years fought against
pressures to compromise and against the
weakening of international resolve to
compel iraqi compliance
without u.s vigilance and determination
in the face of international apathy and
fatigue iraq would resume developing
weapons of mass destruction threatening
his neighbors and destabilizing an
already precarious situation in the gulf
now we face a new situation in which
frequent press reports allege
that u.s leadership is slipping and that
we are backing off surprise searches of
suspected iraqi weapons site
the washington post reported last month
that the united states had discouraged
some aggressive challenge inspections
since last fall
even as we were threatening the use of
force against iraq
the administration has denied these
allegations of interference and argued
the overall context of activities
must be more carefully considered
our witness today resigned in the wake
of these charges of inspection
interference and is before this joint
committee to express his thoughts about
united states and u.s policy toward iraq
let me say before listening to scott
ritter's testimony
that u.s policy and behavior towards
iraq must be unwavering and unrelenting
we must stop weapons of mass destruction
from being produced in iraq
we must insist on comprehensive
inspections and unconditional access to
enforce the assurances on compliance
given by iraq at the end of the gulf war
we fought and led the international
coalition against iraq in desert storm
war to ensure
that victory would lead to an
international effort to rid iraq of all
stocks and materials supporting weapons
production
we must be insistent on this there must
be no exceptions no waffling no seepage
in our determination and our leadership
if there is iraqi non-compliance
and iraqi non-cooperation
we ought to not just threaten force we
should employ it
we should consider doing so with or
without international cooperation
the stakes involved are not trivial
i look forward to hearing mr ritter's
testimony i thank you mr chairman
i now recognize senator levin
the ranking minority member of the
committee on armed sepsis for any
opening remarks he would like to make
thank you very much mr chairman and the
subject of u.s policy regarding u.n
inspections
of iraqi sites is a very important one
and it's appropriate indeed that our two
committees should hear from today's
witness
i understand that our two committees are
going to have an opportunity to hear
from secretary of state albright
secretary of defense cohen next week on
this subject
mr ritter let me add my welcome to you
to this committee i want to thank you
for your work in your recent capacity as
chief
of a united nations special commission
unscom team carrying out inspections of
iraqi suspect sites
on march 2nd of this year i visited with
unscom executive chairman richard butler
in his office at the u.n headquarters in
new york concerning unscom's inspections
relating
to iraq's weapons of mass destruction
programs and their means of delivery
that visit eventually led to chairman
butler's trip to washington for a
classified briefing
for all senators
on unscom's efforts
that briefing which was attended by
almost all members of the senate
gave us all a real appreciation for the
work that mr ritter and the other
members of unscom have been performing
for the last seven years
i believe
and i surely hope that we all agree on
the goal of getting iraq to comply with
united nations security council
resolutions
including the destruction
of iraq's weapons of mass destruction
programs and any means to deliver them
i don't know how anybody could disagree
with that goal
it must be and remain a goal of the
united states until it is accomplished
now there have been differences as to
how to achieve that goal
last january in february
when the administration was preparing to
carry out military strikes against iraq
in response to iraq's refusal to permit
unscam inspections
there were differences of views within
the senate about the use of force
and i'm sure there are differences today
the town meeting at ohio university with
secretaries albright cohn and national
security adviser berger
reflected a variety of views among the
american people as well
for example these are some of the
some of the questions which need to be
faced from a policy perspective
if saddam hussein
does not back down to another threat of
military strikes and the assembling of
u.s forces
as he did in february are we prepared to
follow through
would military strikes achieve our
objective
or
would they galvanize sympathy for the
plight of the iraqi people under the
yoke of saddam hussein
if military strikes did not achieve our
objective
would it be desirable to use u.s air and
ground forces
to remove saddam hussein from power
to achieve the objective and perhaps the
key question of all if i introduced a
resolution this afternoon
to authorize the president
to use all necessary and appropriate
force
to compel iraqi compliance with u.n
resolutions
how many senators would be willing to
support it
would a majority of the senate
do something which they were unwilling
to do a few months ago
which was to support that kind of a use
of force
by the president of the united states
to
compel iraqi compliance
with u.n resolutions
last january and february the senate was
unable to reach agreement on the
appropriate wording of a resolution
supporting the use of u.s military force
against iraq to compl to compel
compliance with u.n resolutions
i don't know if that has changed today i
would hope it would
but i do not know and i have real
questions as to whether or not a
majority would indeed support such a
resolution
now complicating the matter or the
issues as to whether we could obtain
international support for the use of
force and if not
whether or not we should act
unilaterally and of course what the
impact of the use of force
would have on other important american
objectives
those are some of the
complicated issues that merit
consideration
i hope this and subsequent hearings with
representatives the administration will
help us address them
but
in any event i want to add my voice of
welcome and i think every member of this
committee uh would and will uh add their
voice of welcome to you mr ritter look
forward to your testimony and thank you
for your endeavors to try to accomplish
these very critically important
inspections
finally let me recognize senator biden
the ranking minority member on the
committee of foreign relations for any
opening statement he would like to make
thank you mr chairman
i am not objecting but i wish we could
have had this hearing at a time when
secretary of state and secretary of
defense were sitting with you but we'll
have a chance to do that next week let
me begin by saying i think major you've
provided have provided and are providing
a very very very
valuable service to your country by
coming forward as you have
because quite frankly i think what
you've done is you've forced us to come
to our milk here all of us in the united
states congress you forced us to face up
to a very very very basic conflict and
it's a policy decision a policy judgment
that ultimately the administration has
to make and we have to make as well
whether we agree or disagree with them
and hopefully come forward and state it
you have clearly stated from what i've
read and i expect to hear today
two of the most likely options available
to us in terms of policy
one
and i hope that at the end of the day
not literally this day but the end of
the
debate and the political
um
gain and loss that falls out from your
appearance and the things you've raised
i hope at the end of the day
we end up taking the stand an
unequivocal stand we in the congress we
in the senate in particular
and uh i hope we won't shrink from the
choices that you've basically presented
to us you've stated very clearly that
your view
your view in several ways as i read your
statements in the past and your written
letter
you say the illusion of arms control is
more dangerous than arms control at all
a view shared by significant number of
very prominent americans serving in and
out of the congress implication being
what we have now is the illusion of arms
control and i it's hard to deny that
that would be
a a reasonable characterization
you've also stated and i quote that the
decision to seek diplomatic alternatives
to inspection-driven confrontation with
iraq end of quote was one of the reasons
why you stepped down
very clear precise statement
that this notion of inspection driven
confrontations of iraq was an
alternative that was shelved by the
security council shelved by the united
states at this moment and diplomacy was
of course sought and obviously you
disagree with that as many many experts
do
and also although this is not a quote
you have stated that you believe iraq
and saddam have made a very basic
decision that they can absorb the kind
of air power we threw against them the
last time and it's a price worth paying
to be able to maintain and at a minimum
of modicum at a maximum a significant
portion of their program related to
weapons of mass destruction and the
ability to use them
the alternative view the alternative
view seems to be and i'm not getting
this in the administration we'll hear
whether this is correct
seems to be that a policy is the primary
policy is to keep sanctions in place to
deny saddam the billions of dollars that
would allow him to really
crank up really crank up his program
which neither you or i believe he is
ever going to abandon as long as he is
in place
and but that doesn't uh guarantee if
these sanctions are in place that the
program is going to be curtailed
anything other than curtailed doesn't
guarantee that we're going to be able to
stop it i think you and i believe and
many of us believe here as long as
saddam's at the helm there is no
reasonable prospect you or any other
inspector is ever going to be able to
guarantee
that we have rooted out root and branch
the entirety of saddam's program
relative to weapons of mass drug mass
destruction
and you and i both know and all of us
here really know and it's the thing we
have to face that the only way the only
way we're going to get rid of saddam
hussein is we're going to end up having
to start it alone
start it alone and it's going to require
guys like you in uniform to be back on
foot in the desert taking the son of the
taking saddam down
you know it and i know it so i think we
should not kid ourselves here they're
stark stark choices
i happen to agree with your assessment a
that diplomacy was picked over
inspection driven confrontation
b that there's an illusion of arms
control that cannot guarantee he will
have no system of
no weapons of mass destruction and
see that as long as he's there he's
concluded he can absorb air strikes so i
think you've done a significant service
for this country a different
a different policy judgment has been
made
if we don't like the policy judgment in
my view from observation has been made
by the administration and the security
council and our allies if we don't like
it we should step up to the ball and say
it because you forced us and i think
properly so today a reckoning here about
what our policy should be i look forward
to hearing what you have to say
and welcome even without the secretary
of state and secretary of defense
major ritter
i understand that you have an opening
statement please proceed
mr chairman members of the committee
last week i resigned my position with
unscom out of frustration
because the united nations security
council and the united states as its
most most significant supporter was
failing to enforce the post gulf war
resolutions designed to disarm iraq
i can speak to you today from firsthand
experience about the effectiveness of
american policy or lack thereof with
respect to the united nations effort to
rid iraq of its weapons of mass
destruction
i sincerely hope that my actions might
help to change things
it was very sad to hear the secretary of
state on tuesday night giving an
interview from moscow challenging my
credentials
she told the world through cnn that
scott ritter doesn't have a clue about
what our overall policy has been
that we are the foremost supporters of
unscoum
i do have a clue in fact several all of
which indicate that our government has
clearly expressed its policy in one way
and then acted in another
such clues include various statements by
the secretary of state
a report to congress on 6 april by the
president of the united states
and several statements made to me and to
other unscom officials at a variety of
interagency briefings held at the state
department
the pentagon and the white house
if these were the only clues the
administration's record would be
impressive
however i can say without fear of
contradiction and with the confidence
that most of my former colleagues agree
with me
that those clues derived from the
practical experience obtained on the
ground in iraq and behind the scenes at
the united nations tell another story
that the united states has undermined
unscom's efforts through interference
and manipulation usually coming from the
highest levels of the administration's
national security team to include the
secretary of state herself
iraq today is not disarmed and remains
an ugly threat to its neighbors and to
world peace
those americans who think this is
important and that something should be
done about it have to be deeply
disappointed in our leadership
i'm here today to provide you with
specific details about the scope and
nature of interference by this
administration in onscom the
debilitating effect that such
interference has on the ability of
unscum to carry out its disarmament
mission in iraq and to appeal to the
administration and to the senate to work
together to change america's iraq policy
back to what has been stated in the past
full compliance with the provisions of
security council resolutions to include
enabling unscom to carry out its mission
of disarmament in an unrestricted
unhindered fashion
only through the re-establishment of
such a policy clearly stated and
resolutely acted upon does the united
states have a chance of resuming its
leadership role in overseeing the
effective and verifiable disarmament of
iraq
so need so that neither we nor iraq's
neighbors in the middle east will be
threatened by saddam hussein's nuclear
chemical or biological weapons or
long-range ballistic missiles capable of
delivering such weapons
within the confines of the need to
protect the sources and methods used by
the special commission to gather
relevant information i am prepared to
give you whatever details i can so you
will understand why i gave up such an
interesting challenging and meaningful
position in which i had hoped to have
the chance to contribute to making the
world a little safer
thank you
we'll now have five minutes around by
the different senators
i will now take my five minutes
majoretta
and what specific way is to your
knowledge
the united states or united nations
officials
discourage any of your challenges
or challenge inspections
the the united states has
first of all let me start by saying that
the united states has been the foremost
supporter of the special commission and
as such has been the nation which has
encouraged the special commission in
setting forth on missions of discovery
in iraq to expose iraq's retained
capabilities
having established such a policy however
the united states has on repeated
occasions
put pressure on the executive chairman
of the special commission and put
pressure on member states of the
security council to withhold support and
to
encourage the executive chairman to
stop postpone or cancel
inspections of discovery inside iraq
majorella
in several press accounts
you alluded to possible discoveries not
made because of u.s intervention
what do you believe
you own the voyage of discovering in
iraq
mr chairman my job as the chief of the
consumer investigations unit with the
special commission was to expose the
mechanisms used by iraq to hide their
retained weapons capabilities from
discovery by united nations weapons
inspection teams
therefore my job was to
expose this concealment mechanism
break through this concealment mechanism
and get to the retained capability
so the discoveries that the team that i
was in charge of and the special
commission as a whole were on the verge
of making and indeed have made in the
past include
defining with certainty what this
concealment mechanism was
and closing in on the materials that
this concealment mechanism were
retaining
majority
despite iraq's
refusal to allow the conduct of
inspections to
on at least 25 occasions
and more recently in 1997-98
little progress has been achieved in
ending iraq's wmd program
according to the april 1999 report of
unspecial commission
i have i understand that the
international atomic energy agency
gave iraq a clean bill of health on this
euclid missile program in its april 1998
report
in your opinion has iraq entered its
nuclear missile program
and second why are the u.n and the iaea
at odds on this matter
mr chairman with all due respect i
cannot speak on behalf of the
international atomic energy agency
nuclear disarmament issues in iraq are
their purview but what i can say is that
we have clear evidence that iraq is
retaining capabilities prohibited
weapons capabilities in the fields of
chemical biological and ballistic
missile delivery systems of a range
greater than 150 kilometers and if iraq
has undertaken a concerted effort run at
the highest levels inside iraq to retain
these capabilities there i see no reason
why they would not exercise the same
sort of concealment efforts for their
nuclear programs
majoretta
you have been highly critical of u.n
secretary general coffey and anne
for being sympathetic to iraq and
grievances
on what information are your criticisms
based
do you believe that mr nan is working in
good faith to help achieve a full and
complete accounting of iraq's wmd
programs
mr chairman the secretary general is a
man of peace a man responsible for
providing leadership to the united
nations secretary and to the united
nations as a whole it's a very important
task however his task does not include
managing the work of an organ of the
security council the special commission
which was established by the security
council to carry out the resolutions of
the security council i believe that it
is inappropriate for the secretary
general who does not understand the
nature of the work of the special
commission to be involved in managing
the work of the special commission
majoretta
this administration citing his support
for onscom points to your inspections of
presidential sites
in the immediate wake of the saddam and
then agreement
do you believe this is a fast statement
could you replete repeat that question
sir the administration citing your
support for onscom
points to your inspections of
presidential sites
in the immediate wake of the saddam
anand agreement
the question is do you believe this is a
fast statement
mr chairman the inspection to
presidential sites in iraq were farced
from the beginning and actually
represented one of the setbacks of the
special commission it is part of a
continuing cycle of confrontation with
iraq in which iraq
it gets concessions from the world body
to include the united states and the
security council in the case of
presidential sites the presidential side
issue iraq is the one who shaped the
issue of presidential sites the special
commission never
had intentions of inspecting
presidential palaces we never wanted to
iraq defined this problem the united
states and the security council embraced
this problem and as a result of the kofi
annan memorandum of understanding of 23
february we now have a new category of
sites presidential sites which require a
new structure the special group which
through the complexity of this structure
prohibits
in a de facto way the special commission
from being able to carry out no notice
inspections of large areas of iraq
to include areas where we know
material related to iraq's past
prescribed programs are so i don't
believe that the u.s support of
presidential site inspections has
furthered the work of the commission in
fact i believe it's done harm to the
work of the commission my time is up
senator luga thank you very much mr
chairman mr ritter in your letter of
resignation you stated the issue of
immediate unrestricted access is in my
opinion the cornerstone of any viable
inspection regime
and as such is an issue worth fighting
for unfortunately others do not share
this opinion including the security
council and the united states end of
quote
in response to senator thurman
you've already illuminated this somewhat
by indicating as i hear you that the
uh kofi anand regime that was brokered
last year does not give you unrestricted
access to sites in other words you have
described sites that are clearly off the
reservation is that a fair
interpretation of your comments yes sir
paragraph four of the memorandum of
understanding establishes a new category
of sites the presidential sites where
there's a new regime of inspection that
applies restrictions to our ability to
do our work yes sir
why
did the united states agreed to this in
other words if in fact our objective was
as you've suggested unrestricted
access uh clearly
we cannot obtain this during the last
few months that has not been an option
for you apparently
yes sir again i believe that the
february
agreement is part of a cycle of activity
which has started earlier much earlier
in in fact the summer of 1996 in which
iraq provokes a confrontation with
weapons inspectors knowing that there
will not be consensus for decisive
action in the security council and as a
result gets a concession from the
security council the what happened in
february is such a concession
um why the united states supports this
is that they i believe they are
understanding that it's difficult to put
together a coalition and uh they want to
keep the inspection process moving
forward however they're in a situation
where by saving the inspection process
they're destroying the inspection
process and this is one reason why i
felt the need to resign i would not be
part of a destruction of something of
this nature so as senator biden has
analyzed it
essentially we are in a situation
whether we've described it or
articulated to the public or not
that we're hopeful of keeping a security
council
uh majority and certainly the the big
five to keep uh a regime of sanctions on
iraq so that iraq would not obtain the
income
really for truly explosive or dynamic
developments in our in our own way
although we've not articulated this we
have been willing to leave things at a
dull roar in terms of whatever is going
on
in the hopes of staving off through
international cooperation something that
would be more explosive
is is that a reasonable policy granted
we'll find out when we talk to secretary
albright whether that is the policy but
we're attempting to try to formulate
what we are doing in the united states
because it's not clear to the public at
all what we are doing but it may be
we've come to a conclusion
that uh this is about the best we can do
and if so uh maybe a credit should be
given to those that are constraining it
but what is your own view as somebody on
the ground and as privy to these
meetings you've described in the white
house defense department and what have
you yes so one of my frustrations is
that the special commission has been
handed
what indeed is a good task to rid
the world of iraqi weapons of mass
destruction
and the security council in passing its
resolution under chapter 7 said that it
was an enforceable task
the special commission has worked
closely with member states of the united
nations to include the united states on
defining
methodologies and tactics and inspection
approaches towards disarming iraq and as
recently as may 1997 the united states
embraced
our the special commission's concepts on
how to approach the concealment effort
that's what makes this so frustrating is
because this cooperation this
coordination was clearly reflected in
the six april president report by the
president of the united states to
congress
and we believe that after the kofi anon
agreement despite the restrictions
placed upon us that would we would be
allowed to get forward with our mission
of disarmament
that was the stated policy of the united
states however
following the president's report
by mid-april the red light had been
given the special commission by the
united states saying that we will not
condone
inspections of discovery meaning the
kind of inspections that i was charged
with
executing in iraq which would lead to
confrontation we would not support
confrontation with iraq over the right
of inspections for the purpose of
gaining access to sites
mr chair this is what this is all about
we are an inspection organization we
need to conduct inspections to find
these weapons and if you stop us from
doing our job
what does that say iraq is allowed to
have these weapons is a very frustrating
experience
my last question is on this
confrontation uh situation if that has
in fact been the administration's hope
to avoid confrontation and to keep the
security council going
confrontation means military action it
means coming up against once again the
hard issues that senators have talked
about today
i do not agree that we would have taken
a position other than confrontation
in the last go-around uh and but that's
for each one of us to to count the votes
as to where they were i i would say that
if that is what you were saying however
now you are as as senator biden once
again as as pointed to to the fact that
hard issues are here that is to what
extent is the american public
and through its armed forces through its
representatives
prepared really to be credible
to the extent that we are not credible
it appears that we are in for a long
siege uh and we will not have very many
inspections
and at the margin we will have seepage
with regard to the iraqi policy um
in your in your own inspections out
there what was the feeling
of the inspection team
as to where the congress stood where the
public stood in other words did you have
a feeling that you were operating
as lone rangers out there without the
backing of people or was it your
judgment that essentially we were
credible
in a military sense with kofi and anna
himself saying there would have been no
diplomacy without the credibility of
united states military power
yes sir the the weapons inspection teams
to include the one that i was in charge
of
um we don't base our decisions to do
inspections upon the internal domestic
policies of any member state of the
united nations our job is clearly set
forth in security council resolutions to
disarm iraq through the process of
inspection
however i can say that in my role as
chief of this uh
investigation team and i had very
detailed coordination with the members
of with administration people in the
united states government which
established that they did clearly want
us to carry out these missions of
discovery knowing full well that because
these missions of discovery went to the
concealment mechanism the concealment
mechanism which is operated by the
president of iraq's own personal
security forces that these had inherent
friction which would inevitably lead to
confrontation
we were told that this is a good thing
to do we agree with the special
commission's methodologies go forth and
yet when we try to go forth especially
since april we have been
constrained we have been directly told
do not do these inspections
so on the one hand we felt that there
was
especially out immediately after the
memorandum of understanding implicit
support on the part of the united states
for us carrying out these tasks but
actions speak louder than words and
since april we have not been allowed to
do these tasks largely because of
pressure placed upon the special
commission by administration officials
the confrontation which
was
going to occur
in order to be successfully resolved
would have to be backed up by the use of
force on our part would you agree with
that
the the
issue of
enforcing security council resolutions
belongs to the security council and its
collective member states i am a weapons
inspector i have been tasked with
carrying out security council
resolutions which call for the
disarmament of iraq the security council
has established the law we have been
told to implement the law and if blocked
the security council has promised to
enforce the law how they choose to
enforce it is their business what i am
saying today is we are being blocked
from doing our job yeah but would you
agree that it's important that if
there's a threat of force that that
threat be implemented and not just made
and then ignored if you're going to make
a threat of force to enforce a policy
you darn well better carry out that
threat if you are thwarted would you
agree with that yes sir this is part of
the cycle of confrontation and
concession that i've been talking about
and we can't give concessions if we have
confrontation it must have a resolution
yeah okay and that means then if your
threat of force is credible
it's got to be implementable and there's
got to be a will to use force if
necessary once that threat is made now
that's where we are that's where we were
when the
senate was looking at a resolution to
see if we could support the use of force
to implement that kind of a threat but
it's better not to make a threat if
you're not going to carry it out than it
is to make a threat and then ignore it
because you're really worse off if you
make a threat and then not follow
through with that threat would you agree
with that
senator the threat was made back in the
threat of force the threat of force was
made back in april 1991 when the
security council together with the vote
and pushing and backing of the united
states passed the original ceasefire
resolution
i don't see anything that would have
caused the
the law to be altered iraq has not been
disarmed i would assume that that threat
of force still exists today
would you agree though that it
it needs to be cred it has to be
credible if you're going to success sir
okay now during the
um
mr butler who's the unscammed chairman
was asked about pressure
to hold off on surprise inspections of
iraqi facilities
and and this is what he was quoted this
was after you uh resigned this is his
quote and i want to ask you whether you
disagree with his statement
chairman butler said quote i have never
felt that the pressure
that the representation of those views
would be described as undue pressure or
persuasion
above all
i have never found that they cross the
line
between their legitimate interest in
policy
and my unique responsibility for
operational decisions
never now that's
an exact quote from chairman butler do
you disagree with him on that point
the executive chairman is is a fantastic
person a man of honor and a man who has
one of the most difficult jobs one could
you could imagine he has to not only
confront iraq on issues of disarmament
but he also has to coordinate with a
divided a fractured security council
he works for the security council which
means he works for the collective body
of the security council and he comes
under extreme pressures from the
permanent members of the security
council
i would say you need to take a careful
look at what the executive chairman's
saying and read between the lines
because what he's saying is very
disturbing indeed the fact of the matter
is the united states as the single
most significant supporter of the
special commission
carries a lot of weight when it makes a
phone call to the executive chairman we
cannot do our job without the backing of
the united states
and what has happened is that the united
states a gave us a green light to carry
out these inspections and then through
sleight of hand by
expressing their legitimate concerns to
the executive chairman sought to have
another result that is stopping these
inspections the executive chairman
cannot
say publicly that there is undue
pressure but i am here to tell you today
that he felt this pressure and the
pressure was real
just in terms of his public statement
then putting aside what you say his real
beliefs are just in terms of what he
said publicly do you disagree with that
public statement of chairman butler
what i can say is that i was one of the
executive chairman's close advisors the
closest when it came to the issue of
confrontational concealment related
inspections and i know the executive
chairman's personal feelings and i know
the pressures that he's been placed
under and i would say that that's why i
would interpret these words in a
different manner so that you don't
believe these really reflect his views
no sir i do not
my time is up thank you mr chairman
thank you mr chairman i uh
i envy your
position i i sincerely do i envy the
ability to have such clarity on this
issue let me ask you a question do you
think you should be the one to be able
to decide when to pull the trigger no
sir isn't that what this is about if you
if you adopt the position
that any time
you are denied you you're particular
there's four
groups out there in the specters you're
the group you headed any time you were
denied
that that ipso facto requires the united
states and the security council to act
on what they said they would do which is
to
use whatever means necessary to take on
saddam hussein so you can get into that
particular facility is that not correct
is that not your position
mr senator i have a job to do or i had a
job to do and that was to disarm iraq in
accordance with the provisions
resolutions with all due respect if you
i'm not trying to be confrontational i'm
trying to get this as clear as i can i
really mean this now
you have an absolute logic you put
together a very tight syllogism here
you have indicated that
your job is to disarm the only way you
can disarm is to have access the only
way you can have access is either with
permission
on the part of iraq or if denied
forced access right
compelled access compel well okay compel
you sound like the lawyer and i sound
like the military guy i mean uh
you know compelled where i come from
when my old man said you're compelled it
meant i was forced i mean it was a real
simple proposition it wasn't you know it
wasn't much to debate now there is a
clear logic to that and that's what i
mean when i say i respect your position
but that means that
whenever you choose
a target that warrant inspection
and you are denied that ipso facto at
that moment
the only way your position can be
satisfied or sustained is if the un
security council or the united states
acting unilaterally
uses force
to guarantee access is not that true yes
sir now
that means that you get to choose the
time and place
when we would use force if we use force
no sir of course you do if you choose
the site and it's denied and we
coordinate with the member states to
include the united states and prior to
us going in we have their agreement that
this indeed is an inspection worth doing
okay inspection worth doing everybody's
agreed is worth doing and it gets
stopped yes sir at that moment
we're an automatic pilot as far as
you're concerned
period
no we have fans or butts
now i respect that
but now it seems to me the secretary of
state might have a slightly different
problem
secretary of state might be sitting
there and saying i look over there on
that side now i remember so and so and
so and so and so and so and the 12
people on this side they're all the ones
that said they didn't want to use force
now i'm going to have to go tell the
president now
that we should or secretary cohen
unleash
whatever it takes to get it done
and our military assessment is the same
as the majors
the majors assessment is
privately held but publicly acknowledged
later that airstrikes alone aren't going
to do this
saddam's not going to cave on this so
now here's the deal
i recommended the president have at it
and let the chips fall where they may a
reasonable position for the secretary of
defense the secretary of state to take
but i respectfully suggest scott major
i respectfully suggest they have
responsibilities slightly above your pay
grade
slightly above your pay grade
to decide whether or not to take the
nation to war alone
or to take the nation the war part way
or to take the nation to war half a
halfway
that's a real tough decision that's why
they get paid the big bucks that's why
they get the limos and you don't
i mean this sincerely i'm not trying to
be flip
because i think and that's why i was set
at the outset the reason why i'm glad
you did what you did
we should come to our milk
we should make a decision
but in terms of whether the secretary of
state
has
no more to consider than you do as the
arms inspector
you didn't get in didn't get my job done
get me in
period you made the deal right that's
the deal a deal's a deal get me in scott
ritter i'm ready to go
it's not how it works now maybe it
should work that way
but i wouldn't you acknowledge that if
you were president united states or the
secretary of state you'd sit there and
say now okay
old scotty boy didn't get in we said he
should get in we want him to get in it's
important that he does get in they're
not going to let him in so what are we
going to do now we know that france and
russia aren't going to be with us we're
quite confident china's not we've
already run those traps they're not
there we're not sure where the united
states senate is but have at it boys
go get them and by the way
scott and the boys say air power is not
enough
i think it's a legitimate debate scott
major i think it's a legitimate debate
but i don't think we should be putting
in the context of you have somebody up
there at state saying look how can we
weasel out of this agreement we want to
let this guy out there hang in we're not
we're not this
it's a very practical political decision
same kind of decision general powell
made
same kind decision president bush made
every president every secretary of state
has to do it like i said they get paid
more than you their jobs are held a lot
more complicated than yours
they may have made the wrong decision
and you brought it to light we should
address it we should say straight up
where we are and we should do it and for
that i thank you
but it's above your pay grade
i yield for it
i say
warner
thank you mr chairman uh major um
you've leveled one of the most serious
indictments
against the top level national security
team of this country
that has ever been done in contemporary
times in my judgment
and it is our responsibility to hear you
out as we're doing today
and then allow
that security team to come before the
congress and give its side before we
draw our conclusions
but i'm drawn to
the following statement in your
opening remarks however i can say
without fear of contradiction and with
the confidence that most of my former
colleagues agree with me
is
your former colleague mr butler in
agreement with what you're saying
i don't want to put words in mr butler's
mouth um is he included in that
statement i include the executive
chairman as a former colleague in that
statement i recognize not don't get
technical on him he is a former
colleague
but you've got a very important
statement here which leaves a
severe impact on this senator
however i can say without fear of
contradiction and with the confidence
that most of my former colleagues agree
with me
i simply ask you in that statement most
of my former colleagues agree with me do
you include mr butler
it's my it's my feelings that mr butler
would agree with this statement yes
thank you
i joined with senator levin to bring him
down when he
briefed the senators and speaking for
myself and i think many we have a high
degree of confidence
as i presume you do in his judgments
now
you say very clearly that the united
states
scuttled this inspection program
and you make reference to great britain
were they a full partner a partial
partner or to what extent
in your judgment were they involved
i believe that the united states and the
united kingdom coordinate closely on
their policies towards iraq and as such
they both share equal responsibility for
the actions that took place since april
of 1998 in stopping the work of the
special commission
i've read through
all of your statements very carefully
and
you repeatedly refer to secretary
albright
and in one reference to
national security adviser berger
but really the
third and fourth members of that team
are the secretary of defense
and the
cia director do you have any knowledge
that they participated in this decision
idea i have no direct knowledge of that
no sir
the question of the discoveries you were
about to make relating to vx gas
and there was a considerable amount of
publicity
given to that discovery
do you feel that
that publicity
was a factor in the decision that you
allege
that the secretary of state took
the decision to stop inspections
my understanding of the first of all i
need to make clear that the issue of
discovery of the of weaponized vx in
iraq was done by another team a team
that i was not directly associated with
i'm familiar with their work
it's a very important discovery it's one
that shows clearly that a iraq has not
disarmed and they've lied across the
board about not just vx but once we get
to the bottom of the vx issue we'll find
it exposes additional lies which cause
concern for a number of weapons issues
when that issue became public in june
of 1998
i believe that
the administration was forced to endorse
the findings that indeed there was
weaponized vx in iraq today and as such
they expressed support for continued
inspection operations in iraq to
to disclose not only the vx but all
aspects of iraq's retained weapons
capabilities
but that disclosure do you feel that
that was a factor behind the scenes in
the decision made
as you allege by the secretary of state
i believe that disclosure forced this
administration to turn on the green
light which it had turned off back in
april concerning inspections of
discovery and based upon this perception
and even direct acknowledgement that the
green light had been turned on the
special commission undertook to conduct
weapon inspections of discovery in iraq
to try and find these retained weapons
had this
cessation of inspections not happen
can you provide the committee committees
with any estimate
of how much longer
your teams and others would have to do
their work
and the likelihood of
what they might find
sir that's a question that iraq keeps
posing to the special commission how
much longer will this go on the fact of
the matter is that since april 1991
under the direct orders and direction of
the president of iraq the special the
the government of iraq has lied to the
special commission about the totality of
its holdings we cannot conduct
verification of iraq's compliance with
security council resolutions without an
understanding of what there was to begin
with
iraq not only lied to us in april 1991
in the summer of 1991 they conducted
what they call unilateral destruction
that is they disposed of certain
materials without the presence of
weapons inspectors and then destroyed
the records of this alleged destruction
they also diverted certain materials to
the presidential security forces this
has confused an already confusing
situation
we do not know the totality of iraq has
what we do know is that the declarations
they have made to the special commission
to date are false
and the explanations that they give to
us about how they disposed of weapons
are wrong
and therefore we know we have a job to
do
how much longer will it take i can say
this and i'll echo the words of the
executive chairman if iraq gave us today
a full and final accounting of all of
its weapons of mass destruction programs
and retained
weapons capabilities our job would be
over very quickly
but because we don't have such an
accounting
our job has become a mission of
discovery we must go forth and find
these weapons that iraq is hiding and
that could go on a very long time
especially given the level of iraqi
obstruction today
my time is up mr chairman
thank you mr chairman
first i might observe for our
witness today that
a new precedent may have been set uh
at least during the time that i've been
here i believe it's the first time that
the majority leader of the senate has
actually escorted a witness to a hearing
and
put the senate in recess so that this
hearing could take place
having said that i don't know whether
that's precedent or not
but i want to add my own thanks to you
uh as a
former marine and there are at least
five of us that i can see quickly here
and most of the others have served in
another branch of the service i think
all of us admire and respect what you
have done you have been tough you've
been principled you've been
uncompromising
and you have
acquitted yourself extremely well
under the circumstances
let me just if i may
read a
very short uh
actually a sentence and a half
from uh
former president bush's diary at the
conclusion
of operation desert storm which
incidentally i supported
enthusiastically
and wholeheartedly from the outset
he said on february 28 1991 and i quote
it hasn't been a clean end there is no
battleship missouri surrender
that is what's missing to make this akin
to world war ii
there were no
absolutes back then in destroying saddam
hussein's weapons of terror in their
entirety has
proven to be and continues to be a very
very difficult task
and i certainly share the frustration
that you have felt and expressed today
and have
encountered on uh
previous efforts to try to get the full
compliance and indeed i don't think
anyone would quarrel with your
suggestion that if saddam hussein were
to
fully comply
uh that would solve the question but he
has not indicated willingness and so
discovery and you continue so i'm i'm
i'm with you where you're coming from
here my problem is this
when we had a near confrontation the
last time
which was being
provoked as it has been in the past by
the lack of compliance by saddam hussein
we were clearly
prepared to respond militarily
if
necessary uh
almost unilaterally in terms of the
major force effort and i won't go beyond
that but there was clearly a
a plan in place
to carry out
the enforcement side
because of uh secretary general kofi
annan's mission
uh that was not
necessary
and as one who was prepared to support
what i would call phase one at that time
i would have to confess that i was very
much concerned about phase two what do
you do
if phase one
simply places you in a weaker position
with respect to the international
community the support in the region
the support from the american people
etcetera
that still as far as i'm concerned
remains one of the most
difficult questions to answer with
respect to any use of force
in this particular arena and it's
already been alluded to by several of
our colleagues here
in terms of whether or not the congress
much less the american people the
international community or others would
support such an activity
in your
capacity as a
former marine unit commander if you were
confronted with a situation
where you had both the authority the
desire and indeed on your part the
ability to fulfill a
discrete
mission for a smaller unit
but it would in some way compromise or
undermine the larger mission
or compel responses or consequences that
we were
or that the the larger unit was uh
either incapable of dealing with
unwilling to deal with or it was
in politic for a variety of reasons to
deal with
would you concede that there might be
circumstances
and this goes to the question that my
colleague
senator biden posed in a little
different way that
a decision at a senior level or by the
countries
or in this case the the
security council members or others
might
have consequences that would cause them
to make a decision that might not be
the same decision that you would make if
just your mission alone
was the objective that you were seeking
to obtain
that a lot of speculation involved in
answering this question but what i can
say is as follows
the inspection process is about
inspections
you cannot have a process of inspections
unless you're allowed to carry out
individual inspections
our job of inspection is about disarming
iraq
we choose to carry out inspections of
disarmament when we gather and gain
access to information which leads us to
believe that iraq is retaining weapons
prescribed weapons capability
we only go forward on an inspection not
for the purpose of creating
confrontation that's iraq's
responsibility when they refuse to
comply with their right or their
obligations to work with us we go
forward on an inspection of disarmament
when the executive chairman feels that
through such an effort we will achieve
what we've been mandated to do disarm
iraq
you cannot
say
don't do this inspection or don't do
that inspection and expect the
inspection progress to retain to
be
to have any validity which inspection
would you ask us to stop the one that
leads us to the biological weapons plant
the one that leads us to retain vx the
one that leads us to the hidden scud
missiles which inspection do you want us
to stop our job is disarm iraq we do it
through the inspection process and we
cannot have a process process of
inspections unless we can carry out
every single inspection that the
executive chairman feels must be done in
order to carry out his job it's like
saying you want to save to use your
marine analogy save the marine battalion
by doing away with the rifle company you
can't you got to have the rifle company
to have the battalion you have to have
the inspection to have the inspection
process
my time has expired i would say i admire
your single-mindedness of purpose even
though we may disagree about the larger
picture with that mr chairman i thank
you my time has expired
thank you mr chairman
major ritter thank you for your
willingness to come forward and
testify before us and to be as candid
and outspoken in terms of
stating what you believe is to be the
truth as you have been
i uh because you didn't have a chance to
respond to senator biden i want to give
you that chance but i want to make sure
i understand
what it was you're saying and correct me
if it's wrong as i re-read your
statement
you were not calling
on the secretary of state
or the president or secretary of defense
anyone else to use force
you were saying that you wanted this
government to fulfill its commitment to
allow you full
and complete and immediate inspection of
these sites
you have said that this government has
clearly expressed its policy
one way
the policy being and you go on to
describe what that policy is the policy
being that which was stated by the
president unequivocally in his april 6
statement to the people the united
states into the world
which was stated by the secretary of
state that policy being that we will
absolutely insist on full immediate and
complete compliance with the right to
inspect any time anywhere
and so you very clearly made that the
point you said i think it's important
that something
should be done about it
that is because we have been
told that we i can't go forward with
that having been led to believe
by the unequivocal statements of the
president of the united states
that we could go ahead
that this policy was now determined
that you now think that something ought
to be done about that to allow you to go
ahead and complete these inspections
you state that you are appealing to the
administration and the senate to work
together to change this policy as you
say back to what has been stated in the
past
full compliance with the provisions of
security council resolutions to include
enabling unscom to carry out its mission
of disarmament in an unrestricted
unhindered fashion only through the
re-establishment of that policy
of course it's up to the president in
the congress
secretary of defense to decide what
force to use when to use force i think
it's pretty clear that we all thought
that force would be used if iraq didn't
comply with this but it seems to me
exactly what you've called for is
somewhat different than what senate
senator
from delaware suggested am i right or am
i wrong in that yes sir it's
i'm not second guessing the president
united states i'm not presuming to be in
a position to make decisions on behalf
of him or on the behalf of the secretary
of state what i'm doing is holding the
mirror up
to the senate to this administration and
to the american people and i'm asking
you to look into it
in 1991
you tasked the special commission to
carry out disarmament inspections of
iraq and you said that iraq if they
don't do it because we pass this
resolution under chapter 7 we will
enforce this resolution
and in 1998 today i stand before you to
say that a iraq is not disarmed and b
the united states as a member of the
security council which gave us this
mission is doing other than it has said
it wanted to do it set forth the policy
in six april and
during the course of this summer on at
least the two occasions that i'm
directly familiar with it acted in a way
in total contravention of that policy it
said in april do the inspections we
support you and in july and august it
said don't do the inspections
um
on july 8th 1998 the president united
states wrote a letter to the majority
leader senator lot
in which he said and i quote my
administration will continue to support
unscom's right
as authorized by the united nations
security council resolutions to use the
means of its own choosing to pursue any
evidence of iraqi weapons of mass
destruction programs now you're saying
also in july you were receiving
instructions back indicating that that
was not the policy that was going to be
carried out
what i'm saying is that in july of this
year
and after coordinating with both the
united kingdom and the united states the
executive chairman had positioned a team
of 45 inspectors inside iraq who were
paired to carry out missions of
discovery discovery defined retained
weapons of mass destruction
and based upon intervention by both the
united kingdom and the united states
pressure was exerted on the executive
chairman to have him cancel this
inspection it doesn't sound to me like
that is allowing you to quote use the
means of your own choosing no syrup to
pursue evidence of iraqi weapons of mass
destruction
president in his april 6 message says i
believe
if iraq does not keep his word
the we would have a unilateral right to
respond
he also said the united states remains
resolved and ready to secure by whatever
means necessary iraq's full compliance
with its commitment to destroy its
weapons of mass destruction
i think on the basis of that any
reasonable person would conclude
that you had the authority to go ahead
and demand complete immediate
inspect right of inspection yes sir
no further questions mr chairman thank
you thank you
senator feinstein
thanks very much mr chairman and major
thank you very much for being here and
thank you for doing what you're doing
um
you know i think one of the big problems
is that
with respect to the congressional action
in february
i think the case has never really been
made to the american people and perhaps
even to this congress
and i think what you're doing today is
effectively making the case
because what's clear to me at least
is that united states at this time
cannot afford to be a paper tiger
and neither can the security council
and if that's going to be the case then
we might as well just
pull up our stakes and move away
having said that
i wanted to ask you a couple of
questions because i think what this does
is in essence join
a national debate on the subject
are we going to press
for full inspection are we going to do
what we say we're going to do or are we
going to back away when the going gets
rough
i want to refer if i can to your article
in the wall street journal this morning
and
you mentioned that on july 15th
representatives and i take it use the
word both countries that's the united
states and great britain yes ma'am um
informed mr butler that the time wasn't
right for a confrontation with iraq
and he explained to you that he had no
choice but to cancel the planned
inspections
um
and you put point out that for more than
a month you had uh
positioned a team of some 45 inspectors
in place to be able to carry them out
what exactly were you told at that time
on july 15th
yes
i was told that the
that i would not travel to baghdad and
that the inspection teams who were in
baghdad would disperse uh within the
next two days because there was no
further taskings for them the inspection
that we had planned to carry out would
not in fact carry be carried out what
were you given a reason
the reason was that both the united
states and the united kingdom felt that
the timing was not correct for such an
inspection in spite of the fact that a
we had assembled the resources
in cooperation with these two countries
on the hopes that we would be able to do
a mission of disarmament and b
we had precise information which we
hoped would allow us to conduct
effective inspections of disarmament in
iraq
and then i gather
this was postponed you were ordered to
stand down but remain in baghdad is that
oh ma'am i was in new york at the time
you were in new york the team was
dispersed from baghdad we lost the
capability to carry out the inspection
at that time
all right i want to just move to august
for a moment
uh august 2nd
you were flying to baghdad yes ma'am and
um
you were ordered to remain in baghdad
and was it was it to assemble this same
team for an august 5th inspection not
the same team similar capabilities once
a team each team is unique
and i was compelled after the dispersal
of the first team of 45 to reassemble
the team get it back into iraq and be
prepared to carry out missions assigned
to it by the executive chairman and what
did mr butler tell you at that time mr
butler told me at that time that he
believed that this was a mission worth
doing we had hard intelligence
information about specific locations
where we would find
retained weapons and
evidence of iraq's concealment mechanism
and that he believed that the mission
should go forward but he needed to
consult with members of the security
council
before he could give the final order did
he say with whom he was going to consult
other than just the generic members of
the security council i was there when he
made phone calls to specific members of
the security council
to whom did he make calls he made calls
to the secretary general's office to the
russian
um
to the russian representative to the
french representative and he attempted
to make calls to the british and
american representatives but was
compelled to wait until he arrived in
bahrain to make a final link up did he
tell you what the result of those calls
was
um from the russians we came under
attack for um for a variety of reasons
they accused us of being provocative
they tried to divert attention from the
iraqi actions by bringing up
minor incidents that had occurred
earlier in the month the french likewise
urged caution uh do not create a crisis
was the words used the secretary general
basically requested that the executive
chairman do not refer to what has
happened is a crisis we must downplay
this we must keep this low key
and as far as the united states and the
united kingdom were they were both at
this time opposed to the inspections
going forward were you told why you had
to keep it low-key
again we the idea of creating a crisis
of elevating to a crisis level
means that the security council once
again would be confronted with the need
to enforce its law by locating the
problem the security council would be
able to be given more maneuver room to
find a solution
and were you told the date was to be
pushed back to august 10th
i was informed on the fifth of august by
the executive chairman that the
inspection date would have to be pushed
to august 10 to allow him time to return
to new york brief the security council
and confer closely with members of the
security council and he did do that
he did do that and then what was the
result of that briefing
the result was instructions for me to
depart baghdad the inspection would not
be carried out and the specific uh
elements of the inspection team were to
be dispersed
and on august the 8th that was the date
he told you that all bets were off there
would be no inspection
yes ma'am
let me ask you this question uh just
quickly my time has expired what do you
believe you would have found
if iraq
had carried out its obligations to allow
us immediate and unrestricted access
which we believe they would not i might
i have to tell you that one reason why
we wanted to do the inspection in august
was to define the nature of the
confrontation with iraq
iraq was choosing to divert attention
away from its disarmament obligations
and have the world address an issue a
diversion which was we have a problem
with the chairman we have a problem with
the composition of the special
commission
that's the that's the fight that iraq
was positioned itself to fight the
security council
we urge the executive chairman to carry
out this inspection because the fight we
want the security council and the
members of the security council to
discuss is the issue of disarmament and
that can only be discussed in the
framework of disarmament and that means
iraq stopping a specific inspection in
this case an inspection that hadn't been
allowed to go forward and had we been
given access to the sites we would have
found in most
given the high quality of the
intelligence information components of
ballistic missiles illegally retained by
iraq as well as specific documentation
which listed the exact methodologies and
capabilities of the iraqi concealment
mechanism
i say that with certainty
thank you very much um just repeat the
last words
concealment mechanism yes sir
so it was a very important inspection
in the opinion of myself the executive
chairman and the deputy executive
chairman who conferred on this issue it
was indeed
a very important inspection but there
are at least if you've said at least
five paper tigers the united states
wasn't the only one everybody backed
down
yes ma'am
security brown back thank you
and that
information now
is retained by saddam hussein and the
iraqi government and no confrontation
exists to take it out of their hands is
that correct yes sir
mr ritter i want to thank you for
appearing before us today i think you're
a true american hero
and that future generations will look
back and thank you for the number of
weapons that you destroyed the
inspection regimes that you put in place
and
hopefully we can get back to
doing that so that we can protect future
generations i want to focus
my few minutes that i have on apparent
duplicity that's taken place it's cost
and how we got to this point i don't
want to talk about policy issues as some
of my colleagues have
desired to talk about those policy
decisions were already made
you were implementing or supposed to
implement policy decisions that are
already made and that was to inspect i
want to focus on implementation that was
different from the stated policy
decisions that that were put in place
schroeder
you've stated uh to senator feinstein's
questions the specific nature of how you
were stopped from inspecting in spite of
even as recently as july 8 of this year
a statement by the administration that
you could use the means of your own
choosing to pursue any evidence of iraqi
weapons of mass destruction
and you believed that didn't you that
you had that choice yes sir
and you were not told anything any
different that that policy had changed
had you no sir in fact we're told the
opposite that indeed that was the case
we could go forward with an inspection
and indeed wasn't that even the public
statement from the administration go
forth yes sir
and yet you were stopped on two
occasions
in your opinion
in the absence of a robust inspection
regime
how quickly could iraq restart its
weapons of mass destruction program
iraq has
in my opinion within a period of six
months
shortly simply put six months do you
have any information as to whether they
are continuing with it to even today
you do yes sir opinion about that
continuation of their weapons and mass
destruction program today they are posit
itself today that
uh once effective inspection regimes
have been terminated iraq will be able
to reconstitute the entirety of its reta
of its former
nuclear chemical and ballistic missile
delivery system capabilities within a
period of six months
the most difficult of those programs to
continue is the ballistic missile
program would that be correct that would
be my assessment yes sir and you were on
the verge of making a major
confrontation and finding regarding that
program yes sir
and we're stopped then
in being able to do that is that correct
yes sir we prevented from being able to
carry out our mission
ms schroeder i appreciate what you've
done i i think though it actually points
to a broader problem
your principled stand here today though
points out that bigger problem that
credibility is everything
involving foreign policy and now we have
a credibility challenge and a
credibility problem that
statements of one policy publicly and
that privately something goes a
different way
and we're seeing that now front and
center in our policy with iraq
i've had real questions with the
administration what its real policy is
towards iran
uh notwithstanding public statements or
its real policy even towards libya or
russia or israel notwithstanding its
public statements to the to the contrary
i think it seems to me that in foreign
policy issues
you've got to be able to speak clearly
and straightly and not with duplicity or
legalese
or covering over
matters of
stating it one way and then taking
actions another way
that i think
really involves probing of us by other
countries it appears to me that saddam
hussein has decided that he can probe
the united states
with
without us taking action
is that your estimation
yes sir it's not just the united states
but also the world collective especially
the security council saddam hussein has
stood up to the law of the security
council and as such has confronted the
security council and its member
components to include the united states
with their um their impotence in the
face of his continued obstructions
shooter is onscom able to maintain its
long-term monitoring equipment at iraqi
facilities the equipment can be
maintained the effectiveness of the
utility of that equipment is
questionable given the fact that we
cannot carry out the full scope of
inspections required to monitor iraq on
a meaningful basis
what might iraq do to dismantle
long-term monitoring capabilities as a
next step in its confrontation with
onscom i believe that the next logical
step in this would be to expel the
the remaining u.n inspectors from iraq
you anticipate that that will happen yes
sir
so that we're just going to erode away
from any sort of inspection regime
whatsoever with iraq
we have no meaningful inspection regime
in place today and if the situation is
allowed to continue as is we we may end
up with no inspection regime in iraq mr
chairman
my time's up but i think this points to
well we can talk about policy issues and
we should at some time i think this
witnesses point us to a much deeper
problem
and that's duplicity of
saying one thing and doing something
else that's far more troubling far more
broad based and something i think we
need to pursue even further
thank you
thank you very much mr chairman uh it's
an honor to be with this august panel
here
to symbol to hear mr ritter mr ritter
nice to see you uh
you were a veteran of the persian gulf
war is that correct
yes vietnam was was my war
so uh you and i understand
war and its price
i might say
i'd like to ask you
should we have taken out saddam hussein
in
1991 sir i'm here to to speak as my uh
based upon my experience as a weapons
inspector and with all due respect i i i
would tarnish the
the objectivity of the special
commission if i answered that question
you fought in the war you fought to uh
to in effect uh disarm him then and then
with unsc for the last seven years
disarm his capability to make war
and that's why we're here today to talk
about
how we do that
looking back
uh at the difficulty we've had with that
and with him
and he continues to play this
cat and mouse game should we have taken
him out in 1991.
there's no question that saddam hussein
is the problem here
all decisions pertaining to his
retention of weapons of mass destruction
in
direct
disobedience of international law are
made by him and him alone and he is the
only one who can make the decision to
comply with security council resolution
so i would agree with you that saddam
hussein
is the problem
how you resolve the problem of saddam
hussein is an issue that's better left
to
to people who whose responsibility that
is and that is why we're here today to
talk with you to get your insight here
and how we do that apparently the
inspection formula
uh for the last seven years has worked
somewhat and i understand it's destroyed
more chemical and biological weapons you
and your wonderful colleagues than was
destroyed during the war is that correct
yes sir
and now we face another impasse
uh six months
or so since uh the last crisis
where we held a had a mirror held up to
us and had to look ourselves in the
mirror and find
what in the world would be our policy
towards saddam hussein
now we have that mirror held up by you
and i appreciate that more than you know
but what do you suggest we do now
sir that's not my job i have to
respectfully remind you of the fact that
for the last seven years i have been a
weapons inspector in iraq tasked with
discharging the responsibilities of
disarmament i'm here today because we
weren't allowed to do that job now who
did not allow you to do the job was it
the security council there's a
collective responsibility the security
council is the body responsible for
enforcing its law in this case the
security council resolutions passed
under chapter 7 calling for iraq to
disarm but the united states as
a member of one of the five permanent
members and in fact as the single most
capable and responsible member of the
security council the single nation to
which the world looks to to exercise
leadership i hold the united states
directly responsible because it is a
failure of leadership to get the
security council to enforce its own laws
and you would recommend that this united
states government do what now
i re recommend that the united states
government
seek to allow the special commission to
carry out its tasks in conformity with
the policy that had been set forth by
the president of the united states in
his sixth april report to congress and
saddam hussein has said the inspectors
can't go back in now what that's a
decision that's made by the president
united states
do you see our choice between uh
inspectors on the ground in war
this again is a decision
i am charged with carrying out a law
that the united states says is a good
law a law that should be carried out
in so doing the united states together
with the security council has seen fit
to send us in harm's way in iraq to
carry out disarmament inspections and we
have tried to do that for the last seven
years
i'm telling you today we are not able to
do that and i am we are reporting back
to the security council that that is
indeed the case and in january when we
did this drill
earlier this year
we had a choice between making the
inspections work and war
and
saddam hussein backed down because he
thought we were going to inflict
unacceptable pain on him
now we have that choice again it seems
to me that's i think that's our choice
do you see it that way no sir what i see
that occurred in january is that the
united states
faced with the fact that it was that its
bluff was going to be called about the
use of military force engaged the office
of the secretary general to intercede on
its behalf in the behalf of the security
council with iraq and gave iraq an
opportunity to back out
do you looking back do you think that
was a good idea or a bad idea it's a bad
idea it's part of a
of a systematic process of confrontation
and concessions
and the more we do this cycle of
confrontation and concessions the weaker
the collective body of the security
council gets the more ineffective the
inspectorate the special commission
becomes and the more resolute saddam
becomes in keeping these weapons because
now he believes honestly that he can win
and that means that we have fewer and
fewer choices does not mean a choice we
either make the inspections a regime
work or go to war with him is that
correct i think it means we either make
the inspection regime work or iraq is
allowed to retain weapons of mass
destruction
how we make the inspection regime work
is a
decision that the collective of the
security council or
individual action by a member nation
decide to do
senator mccain
i want to thank you mr ritter for being
here and
i one of my colleagues mentioned that
the senate had gone into recess uh
perhaps he didn't know that the senate
went into recess because the other side
objected to this hearing taken place the
only hearing that they objected to so in
order to hold it
you we had to go into recess
so i agree with my friend from virginia
who said it's unprecedented uh
i want to say mr ritter that uh
i appreciate your courage i appreciate
the fact that you've given up
a a very important position because you
felt that your obligation is to the
american people
and
some of us who fought in another
conflict
wish that the congress and the american
people had listened to someone of your
pay grade
during that conflict and perhaps there
wouldn't be quite so many names down on
the wall so
we appreciate the fact that someone of
your pay grade
would be willing to come forward
with this vital information
uh
when you
said that
what do we do now and the choice
is that we
either
carry out the inspections according to
the conflict uh resolute ceasefire as a
result in 1991
or we allow saddam hussein to move
forward
with his acquisition of these weapons of
mass destruction
how serious a problem is that if he
moves forward mr ritter
miss senator the um
as you correctly stated
this issue is
is indeed part and parcel of the war
that was fought in 1991 a war in which i
participated in a war in which hundreds
of americans lost their lives to achieve
a specific aim that was the liberation
of kuwait
in april of 1991 as part of the
ceasefire resolution
the security council added preconditions
to termination of conflict these
preconditions were that iraq must disarm
be rid of its weapons of mass
destruction in doing so the security
council set forth a marker on on the
table saying
we are taking a collective decision to
play a role in non-proliferation and
disarmament activities in the world and
the united states in supporting that
said this is a good role for the
security council to do
what we have today is two
in two things one
the ceasefire resolution is being
violated on a continual basis by iraq
and if we do not take action to turn
this around we will have in fact lost
the gulf war we will have in fact
dishonored those americans who died in
the gulf war and those americans who
paid a heavy price personal or physical
through the conduct of the gulf war but
even worse
saddam hussein will have disgraced the
body of the security council and isn't
on the unfortunate aspect of this and
perhaps one of the motivating factors in
you moving forward is the united states
is articulating one policy
when in reality
they are doing exactly the opposite
isn't that the problem here yes sir
uh and that's what's disturbing to so
many of us seven months ago the
secretary of state threatened force
if these inspections weren't allowed to
be completed
and now apparently from what you and
other evidence that we have is the
secretary of state is arguing against
the completion
of the inspections i'd like to get back
just for a second to the gravity of this
situation
do you believe that
sodom hussein today has three nuclear
weapons assembled only lacking only the
fissile material
the special commission has intelligence
information which indicates that
components necessary for nuclear three
nuclear weapons exist lacking the
fissile material yes sir
so that means to you that in what period
of time
if these inspections cease that
sodomassan will have that nuclear
capability
it's it's question of how he chooses to
acquire enriched uranium either through
indigenous enrichment or through
procurement from abroad
it would if it's indigenous it would
take some time because the iaea has
effectively dismantled the um the
internal enrichment but they have not
dismantled the weaponization program per
se
so what period of time are you talking
about roughly
for total reconstruction would be a
period of several years to reconstruct
enrichment capability
yes sir
and the uh biological and chemical
that's a much uh that it's much less
time frame i believe within a period of
six months iraq could reconstitute its
biological weapons and chemical weapons
capability
and the missiles to deliver them within
a period of six months we know in fact
that iraq has a plan to to have a
breakout scenario for reconstitution of
long-range ballistic missiles within six
months of the ghost signal from the
president of iraq
so it is your uh opinion that
if these
inspections
are further emasculated then within six
months period of time
saddam hussein would have the capability
to deliver a weapon of mass destruction
yes sir
i have no further questions mr
senator kerry
thank you mr chairman uh
i just want to begin with one question
and then i i think i want to just share
some thoughts with my colleagues but uh
in your article today uh mr ritter you
said according to people present during
these consultations
you're referring to the consultation
with mr butler and miss albright
uh the secretary of state made a strong
argument against the inspection being
allowed to go forward who were the
people present during those
consultations
one reason why i didn't who are you
referring to i'm referring to
the executive chairman the deputy
executive chairman of the special
commission
is there any possibility that that
consultation took place privately
between the deputy chairman himself on a
secure phone and no one else present
again sir i wasn't there so that's
speculation what i know is that i was
informed by two parties
both of them informed you yes sir people
informed you of the chairman himself and
the deputy chairman yes sir fair enough
now i began with that question just
because i i spent a considerable amount
of time today on the telephone with
chairman butler
and i just and i don't want to
compromise anything that he said to me
or our discussion head but i want to say
this to my colleagues
first of all
i think most of us adhere to the concept
of fairness and and i'd certainly an
important concept in my politics
the reason there was an objection today
by the leader on the democratic side was
the notion that we ought to be here
with both sides point of view this is
too important an issue
to allow five days to go by
without the administration formally here
to answer questions
secondly i would simply say to my
colleagues that this is much much too
important
to allow it to become
somehow politicized in any way possible
and i regret that even that process got
a little clouded today by this process
of having the hearing
that said
and i want to emphasize that said
i'm very grateful to you mr ritter
i think you're a patriot
i know you're a soldier
and i think you've come to this with a
very
pure sense of duty a sense of
responsibility
and with deep frustration for what
you've not been able to achieve and i
accept what you say i believe what
you're saying to us
it may be a nuance here or there of
interpretation
that people can differ with
but you cannot differ with the
conclusion
that the work of unscom is compromised
and it has been compromised for a
considerable period of time in my
judgment
preceding even these intercessions that
you've referred to of the administration
and that's where i want to share with my
colleagues the notion that we're all
operating here
you know off-kilter a little bit
you know saddam hussein has got to be
delighted with what he's hearing here
today and what he's seen in the last
days
because he's winning
his strategy is working
make no mistake about it his strategy
is not to lift the sanctions
his strategy is to build weapons of mass
destruction
and his strategy
has been able to nip away at unscom over
the course of months
so that he's created sanctions fatigue
among our allies
who also have a different set of
international or national interpretation
of interest here
and the fact is that our administration
recognized some time ago that it had
great difficulty
building the coalition to support what
was necessary to let major ritter and
his team do what they do now i happen to
disagree with senator biden
i don't think the issue
was
simply if scott ritter and his team
can't get in then we do something the
issue is much bigger than that
if scott ritter and his team can't get
in
then the fundamental accepted policy of
our country and of the security council
to be able to enforce
the notion that saddam hussein will not
have weapons of mass destruction is
ineffective
and i think that's exactly what major
ritter is trying to tell us and has put
his job on the line in order to
emphasize
but there's really a larger issue than
that
and that's where i say that the congress
has a shared responsibility and the
american people have a shared
responsibility and our allies have a
shared responsibility
because the hard reality is that when it
came time to consider really following
through and dropping some bombs
the american people had doubts and
congress voice doubts and many of us
were in second room 407 when a lot of
those doubts were expressed
now i at the time suggested as many did
that we ought to be prepared to use
force to the point of guaranteeing we
achieve our goals i still believe that
but i know that america hasn't made that
decision yet
and i know my good friends sitting to
the left of me both of them senator rob
and senator kleinland share with me
a stark
memory of what happens when the american
people haven't made up their mind about
sending people into harm's way and using
force
so we've got a major set of choices to
make here and we better make them
we've been sliding into a fundamental
policy of containment
which i share with major ritter the
notion
is disastrous to our overall
proliferation interests and disastrous
with respect to the middle east and our
interests with respect to sodom hussein
and iraq
but we have to make a decision whether
we're prepared to do what is necessary
and i mean to the point of a sustained
targeting of the regime not the iraqi
people but the regime
and now given what's happened in kenya
and tanzania we have to do that in a
climate where the united states may have
to even ask itself whether we're
prepared
to be a country that's perceived as just
willing to drop some bombs on muslim
nations
without the support of other people in
the world
this is not a small issue
and we should not approach it in a way
in the next days that's just working to
find some scapegoats or find some guilty
parties we've got to find out what we're
willing to do and commit to do it
and that's what's going to make real i
think the efforts of scott ritter and
the folks that he referred to so i think
we've got to stop playing around and get
serious about the choices in front of
the country thank you mr chairman
john
thank you mr chairman i mr ritter let me
just repeat it's been said so often but
this is so rare that we see
your kind of
of courage
before at least our committee one of the
committees that's sitting for you today
and i
the acts of principle i just are so rare
now and i i want you to know how much i
appreciate it you're going to take a lot
of heat there's going to be a lot more
coming
and you've shown the courage that you
can do and certainly the knowledge i've
been very much impressed i've
you know we
quite often have high ranking officials
come before my subcommittee that i chair
which is the readiness subcommittee to
try to get them to tell the truth
as to our state of unreadiness of the
vulnerability of our country
and i'm hoping that your appearance here
today and your actions that you've taken
will not only give a little backbone to
uh to all of the american people in our
resolve but also to a lot of our
military leaders who are less than
straightforward in their answers as to
our vulnerability today in our state of
unreadiness so i for that i thank you
very much and i think we'll we'll all
benefit uh from it
uh you've been there uh major ritter for
seven years uh i know that um
you are hesitant about responding to
questions
uh that are not directly within the line
of responsibility that you had from the
job that you resigned
however you we look upon you as an
expert at least i do in that area so i
may ask you a couple of things in terms
of uh
that might you may not be comfortable
answering but
insofar as the at what point
did the united states stop fully
cooperating
with your inspection efforts
it's it's difficult to define fully
cooperating because if you
for the inspectors the issue is black
and white we have a job to do and we
expect to carry it out
in accordance with what the security
council says the united states indicates
that they will support it on a strategic
sense but they must be given the
flexibility to exercise some tactical
discretion but what i would say
is that in april of this year the united
states departed from its stated
policy of allowing the special
commission to carry out its tasks in
accordance with security council
resolution and went to a policy of
obstruction where it prevented the
special commission from carrying out the
time that they went to the policy of
obstruction and i think that accurately
describes
my understanding of it
is that about the time that secretary
albright was assuring us that saddam
would be quote kept in his box unquote
i i have to be honest and say i'm not
familiar with the exact timing of that
quote so i i don't know i do know it's a
time when the president united states
told the congress that the diplomatic
solution had been exhausted and that it
was time for iraq to be held accountable
for complying with security council
resolution in the united states
encouraged the special commission to go
forward with its task of disarmament
uh
mr ritter i let me just make a statement
that i i think is necessary at this time
some of my colleagues are offering a
false dilemma
that we either back down or commit u.s
forces to war
and i don't think that's the issue the
issue is whether or not the united
states will keep its commitments
and defend its national interests
would you agree with that
that's that that is how i am choosing to
couch this problem the united states
must act in a manner which
which uh
keeps up with the commitments it has
made to the security council to the
world to the american people
okay i had mentioned the the statement
about uh kept in his box as offering
perhaps a false sense of security to the
united states we sat in the same room i
sat in the same chair
when anthony lake was up for his
confirmation hearings to be the director
of central intelligence and during that
period of time
it was my interpretation of his remarks
that he gave the president this what i
considered to be the greatest the
statement that
served the greatest disservice to
america and that is when he said over 33
times that now for the first time uh
this country
uh in the contemporary history of the no
missiles aimed at american children and
it's it's very disturbing when you're
living in the threatening world like
we're we're living in right now to hear
those false senses of security uh what i
was going to ask you about was that
you spending nine years over there know
pretty much about the person of saddam
hussein
you remember nine months before desert
storm saddam who said and this is a
quote our missiles cannot reach
washington if they could reach
washington we would strike
then shortly after the ceasefire a
statement that was made that if we had
held off and not
not
gone into kuwait for five or six more
years we would have the missile def uh
means of delivering the weapons that we
have uh
to deter united states do you remember
those statements yes sir
do you think in your evaluation the type
of person that saddam hussein is that he
would hesitate in any way from using a
weapon of mass destruction and
delivering it to the united states if he
had the capability
my experience with the iraqi government
this is a ruthless government and that
it would carry out
such a task if that was the decision of
the president of our major radar i
appreciate your straightforward answers
that you've given to the uh the
questions i'm going to ask you today and
as well as your your actions i consider
you to be a great american my time has
expired but i appreciate you very much
no more on this side is it
senator roberts thank you mr chairman i
want to correct the record right off the
bat uh major ritter is not a soldier
he's a united states marine there is a
difference
thank you amen semper fi major semper fi
and persevere
with all due respect
to some of my colleagues i don't think
the issue is whether or not we are going
to war whether you pull the trigger or
we pull the trigger
or the threat of force the issue is
really as stated by my calling from
kansas
the issue is the credibility
of our national security policy
i know that senator kerry said it might
be a little unfair
with these statements without the
secretary and the secretary of defense
and the national security
folks
mr berger i want to know their point of
view because the stated point of view is
not what you
are witnessing uh
two here and i think we're saying one
thing and we're doing another
and i think there's an inference here
today mr chairman in regards to the
senate's lack of support
uh for the threat of force and i think
that is very dangerous the question is
not whether we use the force but how and
i i admit it i was the one that stood on
the floor along with several others
and asked the tough questions about the
limited strike that was being proposed
in regards to iraq and those questions
were not answered we did not have the
full support of our allies we couldn't
even
have a strike force from saudi arabia
with the use of our planes and our base
and the same thing in turkey we had to
go ahead with a plan in regards to naval
platforms
we had a situation where we don't think
it was planned well it didn't have
anything to do with the use of force and
i must say that it is implied here by
some in regards to our colleagues here
that the united states senate does not
really feel we should use force and i
think that is a very dangerous message
because i will tell you who's paying
attention it'll be saddam hussein in
baghdad it'll be uh mr bin laden it'll
be
those in kuwait who have already
brought an issue before the security
council questioning as to whether we
have the justification in regards to the
missile strikes in regards to terrorism
if you don't have credibility that's the
thing that happens in regards to our
allies not to mention the 27 000 troops
that are still stationed in the gulf if
we can't inspect what in the hell are
they doing over there
that it seems to me to be the question
so i think it's a very dangerous road
that we are implying here uh in this
hearing by trying to saddle you with a
decision as to whether or not we use the
threat of force i don't like that let me
ask you a question
was the planned august 5th inspection uh
completely and unequivocally
pursuant to unscom's mandate to enforce
the 1991 ceasefire agreement with iraq
was there anything about that particular
planned inspection
that the senate should be aware of as we
consider the administration's conduct
perhaps a motive for the secretary and
the national security adviser other than
avoiding a confrontation with sudan
sir the the planned inspection was
approved by the executive chairman in
total conformance with the authority
given him by the security council in its
resolutions
i want to know your assessment i'm on
the intelligence committee
that's not an oxymoron by the way
and
i want your assessment of the
intelligence that you receive related to
force protection i.e warning you and
your team safety did you feel the
information provided was timely tailored
accurate and complete
sir we we don't receive intelligence
about threats to the safety of the team
we only receive intelligence information
pertaining to the targets that we desire
to inspect that's the second question
your assessment of the intelligence
received
related to helping you and your team
carry out your mission again was it
timely tailored accurate and complete
you've made some predictions here in in
response to senator mccain i'm very
hopeful that that intelligence uh suited
your purpose
yes sir we we have established a
mechanism within the last seven years to
get
to try and get as timely and accurate
intelligence to the inspection teams as
possible i would like to also point out
mr chairman the alternative to the use
of threat is probably the statement by
the secretary of state that we're going
to use sanctions let me point out that
under the exemption of oil for food and
medicine it is that revenue that led to
the construction and the production in
the shifa plant in khartoum that we have
now struck with a missile strike
i think there's a paradox here thank you
sir who's next down there
senator hagel
mr chairman thank you
we realize
major ritter
as far as we know that you did not have
a limousine
you did not make the big bucks
but nonetheless we're very pleased to
have you thank you
we uh we understand that
like sergeants and junior officers
and people who
carry rifles and have to actually do the
fighting and do the inspecting
that you may have a perspective
that the big bucks people don't
and i i joined with my colleague senator
mccain
uh and uh his suggestion if we would
have listened a little more
to the riflemen and the sergeants and
the junior officers
before we got into vietnam we might have
had a different outcome so
don't worry about the limousine problem
major we're pleased you're here
major weren't weren't you
mentioned by name by the iraqis earlier
this year when they were so offended
that the inspection teams had too many
americans
yes sir
i suspect that means that they thought
you did a pretty good job
they believe that the inspections that i
was tasked with carrying out were were
closing in on the weapons that they were
trying to retain
yes sir
do you think there's any linkage
between
that
emphasis on your ability your leadership
uh and uh
the call that came from
national security advisor mr berger to
keep you in the compound and then a
couple days later
your uh your boss mr butler telling you
to get on a plane come home i know that
there is concern with by members of the
of this administration's national
security team that my presence in iraq
creates an inherent friction that um
that they seem to find um undesirable
they feel that the inspections should be
or the conflict should be about
inspections not the inspector that's how
they chose to couch this issue yes sir
and we surely don't want to make mr
hussein uncomfortable
have you spoken to mr butler since you
resigned yes sir
can you share any of that conversation
with us i'd prefer not to sir it's
private conversations between myself and
the executive chairman
would you want to hint at his response
to
at all in general terms to your
resignation i would say that the
executive chairman's opinion today
matches that which he made on the day of
my resignation which was that
he views me as a professional and
somebody of integrity and he understands
the work that i did in the past and what
i'm trying to achieve now by by taking
this stand today
following up on some of the questioning
that has been presented here already
this afternoon on on what might
you have found
if you would have been allowed to pursue
your job your objective
and we heard that i think rather clearly
from you
but let's take that uh beyond what you
have already made very clear
uh what is the intent do you believe of
mr hussein
the intent is clear to retain the
capability
to possess weapons of mass destruction
back in he made a strategic decision in
the 1980s to
get this capability he's linked this
capability directly to his person
and
today his goal is to retain this
capability so that he can menace the
region and project himself as a regional
superpower would it be fair to say to
use uh
potential nuclear biological chemical
weapons uh
to blackmail
the region
i believe that the his past statements
can especially concerning the threat in
april 1990 to burn half of israel imply
that that is indeed one of the tactics
that he uses
and and do you think uh
our administration
articulating a policy out front
but in fact
pursuing a different policy behind the
scenes uh plays to uh saddam hussein's
long-term objective
absolutely i want to re-emphasize this
as a ceasefire resolution
and what's happening here to use the
analogy of senator rob
who said that george bush
said this issue lacked a missouri what's
happening now is that we do have a
missouri it's a ceasefire resolution
which states iraq must disarm and what
we have is the vanquished boarding the
missouri and dictating the terms of
conflict resolution to those who won the
war it's a travesty and i'm really sad
that it's happening mr burger's call
to the un mission that you reference in
the wall street journal article today
was that unusual
uh
the the fact that uh mr burger or miss
albright uh called the executive
chairman to offer their consultations is
not unusual no sir but but to
specifically
say you keep major ritter pinned up
that's not the first time that this has
occurred that's not the first time no
sir would you care to enlighten the
committee on other times i can state
that in march of 1998 both
the national security advisor and the
secretary of state intervened on
numerous occasions
with the executive chairman to keep
myself out of iraq as the leader of a
concealment based inspection team
major ritter thank you thank you sir
senator coverdale
thank you mr chairman uh let me first
say
uh working off senator from
massachusetts remarks
regarding the consensus of the american
people
i believe this is a very dangerous time
for every american citizen and every
peace loving citizen
and you cannot build
a consensus or understanding of the
level of this danger by disguising
or making
a false assurance to the american people
yes we are getting the inspection job
done but no we're not
if we're going to build a consensus
you can debate the policy
they can agree with you or agree with
somebody else
but the policy has to be on the table so
that the american people can be at the
table
having said that
i'm specifically interested in the
events surrounding the inspections that
have been planned for january 12 1998
as i recall on january 12th iraq
announced that it would not allow any
further inspections because the team was
dominated by british and american
personnel
were you leading the team in baghdad
when this happened yes sir
what was your reaction to the iraqi
declaration and what did you think they
were trying to accomplish
uh we were allowed to carry out one
day's worth of inspection the issue that
we were pursuing was the issue of iraq's
retention of biological weapons and the
fact that they tested these weapons on
live human subjects in the summer of
1995
and we had during the course of that day
put together a considerable amount of
evidence which would allow us to pursue
that effectively
i believe that iraq's decision to stop
the team and to divert attention away
from the disarmament tasks of the team
towards the issue of composition of the
team
was designed to stop the effective
inspection and again get some sort of
concession from the security council did
mr butler agree with your assessment of
how iraq was trying to dilute the
expertise of the team yes sir
how did you and he agree to resolve this
impasse
yes sir we decided that would be best to
call iraq's bluff
and despite the obvious
desire not to reconstitute the team and
let iraq dictate team composition we
felt that we would we could indeed come
up with a team composition that would
meet iraq's requirements and continue to
carry out inspections and we chose to
carry out inspections of sites which we
had good intelligence information
related to retained weapons in which we
felt iraq would be compelled to obstruct
therefore we would call iraq's bluff and
confront the world with the reality that
iraq had no intention of allowing the
special commission to carry out its
disarmament tasks
so you were confident that iraq would
have refused inscom access to these
sites regardless of who was on the team
thus proving that the objections over
team composition were just a delaying
tactic yes sir
now am i correct that the sso is a key
organization tasked with concealing
iraq's weapons of mass destruction from
moonscum yes sir the special security
organization is the presidential
security force and it's been tasked by
the president to conceal these weapons
and at the time you were the chief of
unscom's concealment investigative unit
yes sir thus i assume that it would have
been essential that you lead the
inspection of the sso headquarters yes
sir
but on january 15th your inspection was
canceled and you never had the
opportunity to expose iraq's objection
to your team's composition as a fraud
what happened
on
basically what happened is that i
received a call from the executive
chairman i was told to stand down and to
withdraw from iraq and to cease the
inspection
so at the request of the administration
you were pulled and the inspection was
canceled and as a result we missed the
critical opportunity yes sir the
executive chairman received another one
of these phone calls from the national
security team instructing him to
withdraw the chief inspector and to
cease the inspection opportunity and we
did not have an opportunity to carry out
the disarmament inspections that we
wanted to
major
as i would say to all members no matter
their rank of the united states military
i thank you on behalf of the american
people and i appreciate your courage
here demonstrated today thank you sir
no further questions mr chairman thank
you very much sen snow
thank you mr chairman and i too uh major
rita want to join my colleagues in
expressing
uh gratitude to you for the service that
you have rendered not only to this
country but to the world and trying to
make it a safer world and also for being
here today
the fact we know that it's not easy
it's not easy to resign a position to
which you have given so much
uh and
we appreciate your forthrightness and
and your honesty and your courage by
being here today and by expressing
your position and the reasons why you
resign from the commission regrettably
because obviously you've made a a
tremendous commitment to this endeavor
which is a very significant endeavor and
i think it's a sheer tragedy
that we're in this position today
because of the failure of the commitment
and not only by our country in this
administration but the other members of
the security council to back up into in
and to reinforce the efforts and the
work of unscum
tell me um i think it's uh frankly i
thought it was rather unusual
for intervention by this administration
with respect to particular inspections
by unscum
um
since you have been on
an inspection teams with since 1991
can you tell me um
was this
similar to previous administration since
you have worked to through two
administrations um had you experienced
similar interventions by the previous
administration with respect to specific
inspections or timing of expense
inspections or types of inspection
we we've always consulted closely with
the united states on
issues of pertaining to inspections as
we've consulted with other members of
the security council and they've all
provided us with their their tactical
opinion but i would say that it's since
uh november of 1997
that the special commission has
encountered specific interventions to
stop given inspections
right and there were six different um
encounters i gathered uh since november
23rd of 1997. is that correct there's
six different instances which
specifically
uh secretary albright intervened to
cancel the inspections or to encourage
the disruption of the inspections
there's at least six there may be more
and it may not have all fallen on the
shoulders of the secretary of state it
could have been other members of the
national security team but the united
states has intervened at least six times
to stop inspection since november yes
ma'am
did
do you know whether or not the united
states attempted to influence other
members of the security council with
respect to the cancellation of these
inspections
i do know that the united states has
exerted pressure on other members of the
security council and other government
other nations supporting nations within
the united nations community
to
maybe not encourage or not give the
special commission the resources
required to carry out its disarmament
tasks yes
did administration officials intervene
in this manner prior to november of 1997
not in such a conclusive way there as i
said there's always consultations and we
might have disagreement of opinion on
consultations but in terms of dramatic
intervention for the purpose of
obstructing inspections um this started
in november
now in in the first instance in november
23rd
as i understand it secretary albright
called mr butler seeking cancellation of
a no notice visit to iraqi republican
guard facility
now she indicated at the time at least
according to newspaper reports
uh that the appropriate diplomatic and
military groundwork had not been laid is
that true in all of the other instances
had any effort been made by the
administration at least from a
diplomatic standpoint to work with the
other countries to ensure that these
inspections could go forward
my understanding of the situation that i
developed through close consultations
with
people in the u.s administration
is that the reason for obstruction
november and december were to buy the
the united states time to assemble a
coalition to assemble um the resources
required militarily and politically and
uh diplomatically to
enforce its resolutions and that by
january when we started our inspection
in january these resources had indeed
been assembled
and that was a particular problem at the
time the failure of the administration
to lay that groundwork
to make your job possible
and
that obviously was an essential
component
of allowing you to do your job and also
to reinforce
the res the united nations resolution
with respect to the use of force to
respond
to saddam hussein in the prevention of
these inspections but obviously that
didn't happen in any of these instances
and obviously these calls were made to
cancel these inspections
yes man
have inspections of any consequence
occurred at all this year
we we have had inspections of
consequence we exposed the vx warheads
through the inspection process we
discovered a document which exposed the
the absolute lie that iraq's told about
consumption of chemical weapons
what i would say is that inspections
designed to
expose iraq's concealment mechanism have
not been allowed to proceed
could you also
tell me why
secretary albright was concerned
about
particularly intrusive inspections
as i've tried to explain to go after the
concealment mechanism you are going
after the forces that protect the
president of iraq he made the decision
to use his personal protection forces to
also protect these weapons
this makes the inspection process
inherently confrontational especially
the inspection process involving going
after the concealment mechanism so
that's i think why these would be a
particular concern
weren't those the basis for the
resolutions that uh that were developed
between the united nations and iraq
yes ma'am
we made a decision that in order to go
after
these weapons we had to go after the
concealment mechanism this is part and
parcel of the requirement to get our act
to disarm
and finally one other question uh have
you during your years as an inspector
ever uncover evidence which indicated
direct personal interest by saddam
hussein in specific chemical biological
weapons
uh yes ma'am we i mean we have uncovered
uh
innumerable pieces of intelligence which
indicate that the president of iraq
directs
specifically directs the financing
associated with covert procurement in
this area and he also is the one
responsible for directing the forces
who do the actual acts of concealment
this is tied directly to the president
of iraq
thank you and thank you major ritter for
being here today thank you
i believe we
don't have enough people who want to
have another round but a few of us just
had one question
and so
i will start and anybody else has a
question be glad give them a chance and
ask it
in light of iraq's most recent refusal
to allow on-site inspections
what is the status of this monitoring
program
the monitoring program requires that the
special commission be allowed to conduct
the full width of its inspection
activities you cannot take treat
monitoring as as one aspect or another
it has to be the totality of all the
inspection tools available to the
commission so the fact that we are not
allowed to carry out a category of
inspections in this case inspections of
discovery means that we are not carrying
out effective monitoring of iraq today
so look i'll review had a question thank
you mr chairman
mr ritter you uh stated in the
washington post uh article at least
recorded saying i know the iraqis are
concealing weapons
and they are violating sanctions that
they are doing their best to for
instance covertly procure
proscribed capabilities
let me ask
in the oil for food program
do you have evidence that they have used
that program
for procurement activities
yes sir again
in accordance with my desire to protect
the sources and methods i can't get into
very many details on this but the
special commission and the united states
government have specific intelligence
information which shows that iraq uses
the oil for food program
to as a front to facilitate the
acquisition of either dual use or
prescribed material you have any idea
the extent uh to which that has occurred
in
terms of either dollar amounts
quantities of anything that can give us
a handle on how serious this procurement
is
it's it's definitely a serious issue the
one issue which i was directly involved
in in a recent case involved
dollar amounts of over eight hundred
thousand dollars
but again we do not know the totality of
this effort we know that it's taking
place and part of our job as inspectors
is to define just to what extent iraq is
violating sanctions and carrying on its
uh weapons programs thank you
thank you john
9 11 thank you mr chairman uh
i understood you to say in response to a
question from senator feinstein that you
did not expect iraq
necessarily to allow you access to the
facilities that you sought to inspect
because of the inherently
confrontational nature but that their
refusal to do so would be useful because
if they refused
to do it then
the world would be confronted with the
fact that iran i mean that iraq was not
complying with u.n resolutions and that
then the world hopefully would be forced
to confront that reality is that a fair
summary of where what you were saying to
senator feinstein yes sir
well i want to thank you for that
um i think that you have indeed
confronted not just the world but the
congress
with this reality
that we've all known about that saddam
hussein
is
thwarting the will of the world
community
that's the bottom line and so far he's
getting away with it because he's been
able to survive the sanctions and we
have a choice as a congress whether or
not we're just going to support a
sanction policy or whether we will do
what we have not done and were not able
to do a few months ago which is to agree
on a resolution authorizing the use of
force
to achieve
what the u n resolution said and he
agreed must be done
that's really what you're confronting us
with
as well as the world and i just want to
thank you for that i think it's a very
useful function and i hope congress
responds not just by
saying
look
he's ignoring
the world u.n resolution and getting
away with it
and look we've said we're going to do
something about it and haven't
but
looking inward to ourselves as a
congress okay will we then
resolve
to use necessary force to force him
to comply with the u.n resolution
or are we just simply going to go along
with a sanction policy in the hope that
that will
somehow rather weaken him you have
forced us
i think to confront
ourselves and what we ourselves have not
yet done which is to come to grips with
this very difficult issue are we willing
to support the use of all necessary
force
to
one way or another
make sure he does not have weapons of
mass destruction thank you for stepping
forward and confronting us with that
choice
mr senator rob
thank you mr chairman just one last
question following up on the
on the
uh analysis as well as the question that
senator levin just asked
and i i share
the collective
appreciation of the entire committee for
what you have done and for forcing
all of us who have policy
responsibilities to come to grips with
the situation that confronts us
you have understandably been reluctant
to suggest exactly what
the executive branch of the united
states government or other members of
the security council might do
in terms of in the specific enforcement
question but i would ask you if you
think that there is anything
short
of the suggestion that was just made by
senator levin in terms of the full
application of military force
that would have accomplished your
specific objections
objectives
as the leader of the inspection team in
other words
would is there anything short of that
particular
approach in your judgment that would
have advanced your cause
to
discover
uh
and both both the
items and the methods of concealment
could could you
take a shot at that as a my final
question okay so thank you
what
again you confront me with the position
where as an inspector i could possibly
taint and a process of inspection that i
want to i hope will continue by trying
to step into the purview of the security
council or the united states but what i
would say is that in june 1996 when this
process of confrontation and concession
began had the security council stepped
up to the plate
and taken the taken decisive measures
the price we would have had to pay for
compliance would have been small indeed
i think a minimal amount of force could
have been applied to iraq to get them to
comply but because the cycle of
confrontation and concession has taken
place now over the course of more than
two years and is continuing to take
place today uh through security council
resolutions that are being discussed
where the secretary general will be
allowed to conduct a comprehensive
review of the inspection team the price
that has to be paid today is much
greater what that price is what exactly
has to be used to compel iraq i can't
define but i know that it will be heavy
it will be
significant history is replete with
examples where if we had acted in some
capacity sooner rather than later the
ultimate consequences might have been
born
more easily but given the situation as
it exists today
and i'm not asking for any specifics
just
is there in your judgment anything short
of the application of sustained force
and all that that implies
that would have advanced your program
no sir
thank you very much major ridger and
again i compliment you
senator coverdale
major i
have a series of questions that i'm
essentially doing for the record
uh i'll read them very rather quickly
and your responses can
be although they've been very direct and
very brief as it is in an interview on
cnn two days ago on september 1st
secretary of state albright made the
following statement
there have been great inspections that
have taken place in the last several
years where we have made it possible for
them unscum to go to the ministry of
defense for them to go into a number of
areas that had never been inspected
before
mr ritter did you or anyone else at
unscom ever argue that there was
compelling evidence to inspect the iraqi
ministry of defense for arms control
reasons
no sir
but the secretary of state is clearly
claiming that the united states made it
possible quote
for yonscom to inspect the ministry of
defense that would imply that unscom
wanted to conduct that inspection whose
idea was it to conduct that inspection
unscums or the united states
the united states has been pressing the
special commission to inspect the
ministry of defense now for since 1991
and both of the executive chairmans have
repeatedly
held off from authorizing this because
there was no compelling arms control
reason presented to them for the conduct
of such inspection
in march the special commission was
again or in february the commission was
confronted with a
request even demand by
the united states that the ministry of
defense be included in the list of
disarmament targets
and the executive chairman was
confronted by members of his staff to
include myself and reminded that we had
no compelling arms control reason to do
this and that um
this was probably heading down a
slippery slope of
confrontation which could not be backed
up by our mandate
but onscom yielded to u.s pressure to
conduct the mod inspection yes sir
when you agreed to conduct the mod
inspection at the request of the united
states what was your estimate of the
time that you needed to prepare for a
thorough inspection of the site
we informed the executive chairman that
we would need up to three weeks to
assemble the number of inspectors
required to carry out an inspection of a
building a facility the size of the mod
approximately 150 inspectors
well you've answered my next question
please explain why you need so many
people and when you got into the
ministry of defense what happened yes
sir we've been telling the executive
chairman and anybody who would listen
that access does not start just by
getting in the door access must be
throughout the inspection we must
prevent iraq from destroying documents
from removing documents and from
hiding documents and material in a site
uh designated for inspection a facility
as big as the ministry of defense
requires us to surround the facility to
block every exit to put observers in
every corridor and to monitor the major
rooms while we proceed with the course
of the inspection so we needed 150
inspectors to carry this task out in
your expert opinion could you have done
a credible arms control inspection of
mod facilities
with that few inspectors in so little
time no sir
did you make your views on this known to
mr butler and thus presumably secretary
albright at the same time
i made my views clear to the executive
chairman
but you were told to go forward anyway
yes sir i thank you for your prompt
response mr chairman i conclude my
questions
senator you have any further questions
no mr chairman
senator luva you're all set
levin thank you mr jurgen thank you mr
well i think we've finally completed the
hearing
i want to thank all the senators who
came and participated in this sharing
i think is one of the most important
hearings
that we have held in a number of years
i especially wish to thank you mr rudder
for your parents
for your excellent testimony
and you have proved that you are
a real patron and a great american
we're proud of you
now if there's nothing else to come
forward to commit at this time
we're now standing join until the call
of the chair
good luck
appreciate all you did thank you strong
now
[Music]
good
[Music]
good
foreign
yes
you can hear more about the iraq weapons
inspections tomorrow morning at 9 15
eastern as scott ritter joins us on our
washington journal program
we invite your thoughts and questions on
the topic by phone fax and email
washington journal airs weekdays at 7
eastern 4 pacific here on c-span